blood survivors in this Village in
rupava District set in silence as
coffins of their loved ones are lined up
for a mass funeral
kamana says he fought to save his family
but the water destroyed everything he
had
um
I was doing everything to rescue my wife
who was stuck by the wall after the
whole house fell down because of the
water from the river the last thing my
wife said to me was don't abandon me and
then my wife fell into the violent water
I fled because I couldn't do anything my
family and children are all dead I am
left all alone
[Applause]
nuts and Landslide killed at least 130
people after heavy rain on Tuesday night
more than 5 000 homes were destroyed
many houses are still underwater and
people have nowhere to go
it's a miracle I survived but my son
died our house was destroyed and the
water took everything away I climbed an
avocado tree and I spotted my family and
two children by Chance the next morning
at the moment we have nothing left and
we don't know how we'll live the
government promised to bring supplies to
the worst affected areas
it is a pity for the victims we are
barring but the survivors must be helped
many of them are still in hospital we
will take care of them and move those
who remain from vulnerable places as the
weather is still bad
rescue workers are still searching the
area and expect to find more bodies
buried under the mud
Barbara angerpa Al Jazeera
still ahead on Al Jazeera we'll tell